pendant un an véronique va partager son
temps entre ses 23 élèves de ce1 et sa
formation de professeur des écoles
pour elle c'est une nouvelle carrière
j'ai été pendant sept ans officier dans
l'armée de l'air
j'ai occupé plusieurs postes dont le
poste professeur d'anglais donc j'ai une
expérience du face à face pédagogique
mais
avec dédé
des adultes donc ce qui est très
différent une seconde expérience avec
des cm1 dans une école privée en
nouvelle calédonie la conforte dans son
idée
elle veut enseigner a déçu de mes études
je voulais devenir enseignante
j'ai choisi les langues de prime abord
mais j'ai toujours eu dans un coin de la
tête l'idée de devenir maîtresse et
voilà l'opportunité s'est offerte à moi
de pouvoir
me reconvertir et donc j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion pour passer le concours nous
préparer pendant un an
et donc voilà on a toutes les chances de
mon côté pour être là aujourd'hui
dans ma classe à guyancourt ce lundi la
voilà dans le grand bain aux derniers
préparatifs
accueil appel des élèves et premier
cours